I see some plastic in there that you
could have avoided this is gonna take
away too much time and I don't want to
buy new things
my name is Joyce and this is my journey
to Z the Z cos I know you talked to me
about my you know boom where's your
waste and stuff and I have a challenge
for you what I'm challenging you to
gather all your trash for 24 hours all
the trash that you make you put in that
bags and you carried her out with you
are you sure it's legit swig alone
well we can get you another rag this is
like a waste on it do you think you
could do it is it too much no I think
we'll be fine
yeah good luck I'm so excited to see all
your trash I really excited you know
what I think that's romantic thing
anyone's ever said to me
so we're gonna start its bagel days so I
got a bagel I wasn't really talking this
cup a ginger ale I want to put that all
in the bag and just walk around with it
I also got a free doughnut so that's
another thing so I got a half a bag of
trash right now which is lit what do you
guys think of my trash bag honestly
because you're caring in this fashion
that much trash when I see you wasting
food okay
we have leftovers and post me as I'm
eating that for lunch today I also have
this cup of water another empty ginger
ale is my trash so far I have a
co-worker and a friend in real life and
her name is Ari and she's always
bringing like forks and bowls like she
always just had everything she needed
and I always thought it was so cool so I
went up to Ari and I was like I want to
know the zero waste thing but we started
having conversations about going zero
waste so Ari give me a reusable plates
so no delicious zero waste so I'm
waiting for my uber home and I got this
bag of trash bout to go in my uber my
movies gonna think I'm pleased when I
think about things about the environment
and what's going on and I kind of feel
very powerless so I believe going zero
waste could be my way of contributing to
make a better world I'm getting rid of
my friend Ashley and I didn't want to
bring the trash bag into the restaurant
here's all the trash I made for my food
so I finished I'm just gonna wrap it up
and put it in my purse
in the trash bin zero waste is cool it's
great for the environment but you know
from my perspective it's for mostly the
white and the rich and the privileged so
it's going to be interesting how much
time money energy it's gonna take for me
to really kind of get to my goal because
I do love the environment sure I'm not
gonna take an Instagram post with me in
a mountain but I care about my mountains
you know and what about my birds and the
bees I'm hanging out like roommates and
you know we decided to have a night end
so let's just back up chips this bag of
chips a bottle I mean I have to put this
all in the trash bag I'm very excited to
dig in your trash yes the thing about
trash it's mostly invisible we throw it
away and we never think about it again
yeah if you're interested to reduce your
waste looking through what you actually
make is really helpful because if you
don't know yeah then how do you know
what to reduce this looks very standard
the average American makes about four
point four pounds of trash per day so
this is very normal
oh I felt like no so what we're gonna do
is separate food waste from things that
could be recycled over and landfill
she's like this handling wet trash that
is actually trash because it's lined
with plastic all utensils are actually
trash because they're so small for the
recycling machine so they're not
actually gonna get recycled so this
maybe could be recycled but it's covered
in food and grease so even if you put
this in a recycling bin it's gonna go to
landfill if you want to recycle
something you have to clean it out
completely if you cleaned it you could
recycle it but only nine percent of
plastic actually gets recycled okay so
looking at this I'm
seeing some really good opportunities
for you to reduce your waste okay what
we're really trying to go after is
single-use plastics do you think that
you're ready for 24 hours or no waste
what we're here to learn I think my
biggest worry said this is gonna take
away too much time and I don't know if I
want to buy new things it's hard because
then you have to refigure or change your
routine and that always takes time and
it's an adjustment not everyone has the
luxury to think about that yeah I don't
think you need to buy anything and it's
more zero waste to not buy anything just
get what we already have or lose that in
order should be like zero waste
throughout the day you need like a zero
waste kit so you're prepared for any of
the plastic that comes at you you can be
like which I will jump which are avoid
avoid the single-use plastic okay so I'm
using one of my usable cups that I got
to get some food for lunchtime and I am
using the reusable plates so I'm gonna
get leftovers I would normally get like
a ginger ale
which is my true drug but today we're
gonna be a convention ho guys it's my
zero waste meal and this is not plastic
it looks plastic it does whatever you go
that lesson don't make them annoying
thank you okay so we're just gonna put
this feed in the organic waste and then
we're gonna wash these dishes veer away
anybody I haven't made trash yet I
really really want a piece of candy
should I get it this waste no candy
today well they're giving free drinks
and I'm gonna try not to make any trash
so I have to be zero waste so I can't
use any plastic cups
[Music]
0h rain okay guys so I'm at the theater
and jazz handed me this water bottle so
I spent the whole day not making trash
and now I have trash I feel bamboozled
because no one told me about this I was
just thirsty I literally I'm carrying a
trash bag in my purse
so thank you jazz I was seven Thank You
jazz I had leftovers but they came in
this aluminum packaging systems also
trash so so far I'm pretty damn good
baby on my own trash a I use this water
bottle aluminum foil and this ticket and
the water bottle was handed to you it
was handed to me I don't think this one
really counts you did so good do you
think so I think you need to me was like
just going straight into it was a lot
and it just took a lot of energies when
I did the month of no trash it was too
much and what really worked for me was
just doing little steps one at a time I
would like to just make small changes
over time and I think it'd be great if
he helped me boo
okay how about okay look sustainability
thank you so much for watching please
comment below on the way to you guys
reduce your trash it's next week I'm
gonna try to get fast food without
making any trash
[Music]